[Music]
hi everyone thank you for joining me
today
my name is Vidya Nagarajan and I'm a
senior product manager at Google working
on the chrome and Android team in
today's session this afternoon we'll be
discussing how to make every screen work
for you whether it's managing a
distributed workforce delighting your
customers or transforming your business
in this truly digital world but first I
spent my formative years in this tiny
country in the Middle East called Kuwait
and growing up I grew up in a household
where both my parents worked and I
vividly remember my childhood where I
used to visit my mother's work space and
I used to be fascinated seeing these
amazing collection of floppy disks and
pens and papers and typewriters and it
used to just completely amaze me seeing
all these desk phones out there and my
mom used to type these documents
electronically and then she would print
them ahead of time to be reviewed during
meetings on paper fast forward to today
whenever my mom visits my workspace
today she thinks things are quite
different of course of course there are
a lot more screens you no longer you no
longer have desk phones right just
phones are replaced by smartphones you
have laptops and of course you have
video conferencing devices so imagine a
workplace where every employee is
completely empowered every employee has
appropriate access to data they have
appropriate access to technology so that
they can be connected they can
collaborate with each other more they
can help the enterprise accomplish their
top goals their organizational goals
they can ship products much faster
quality of products that delight their
customers and overall increase the
organization's bottom line however the
reality is much darker if you actually
look at the world labor stats there are
over three point two five billion
workers today right however there are
only 750 million pcs in business and 300
million managed smartphones so the face
of the workforce is also changing
drastically today this is the world of
the new generation the next generation
the generation of the Millennials and in
this generation they are really born
with a smartphone a mobile phone in hand
my daughters are constantly on their
phone and they use this phone to do
everything it's not just about talking
to their friends and SMSing it's also
about having a lifeline and maintaining
a connection with our friends and family
and it's the same workforce it's the
same new generation who is going to be
in your workforce and they're going to
also be using these phones to do work so
a typical day in my life actually starts
with me dropping my daughters in school
and then I would do a myriad of other
activities in between before I actually
end my day and the activities would
range from I would stop at the gas
station to get some gas I would ride the
elevator to take the floors in my
building I would grab some lunch
I would probably visit the dentist's
office I would work at my desk I would
network with my colleagues I would shop
for groceries in my nearby Safeway store
I would stop by the mall for some shoes
take a taxi to the airport catch a
flight and check in maybe going to a
conference in Vegas if I'm not it next
and then I would probably go at it at
the casino when I have the time so what
is one thing that is common in all these
scenarios what do you see that's really
common in all these scenarios please
don't look at the notes what is common
in these scenarios
it's a screens right so there are
screens everywhere and that's the huge
opportunity so we are all surrounded by
screens everywhere screens are becoming
ubiquitous so we are truly in the midst
of a cultural revolution that is being
completely driven by technology and much
of this technology to fuel this
revolution exists today but it's just
super expensive it's not mainstream
because it's super expensive there are
manageability concerns there are
concerns with energy however
we make more technological innovations
with display hardware innovations sensor
innovations innovations with Bluetooth
Low Energy using energy efficient
environmentally sensitive sensitive
materials you will find that these
screens truly become ubiquitous right
they're gonna be everywhere so every
stop sign out there in my traffic light
will also be a digital sign so this is
an example that I always love to use so
I'm a major art connoisseur I collect a
lot of art and I always keep saying how
amazing would it be that if I were to
buy an artwork from my art museum that's
no longer going to be a scroll of paper
that I take home but instead it's going
to be a digital sign it's going to be a
high-resolution thin flexible display
which shows a new masterpiece every
month right and it has a subscription it
comes with a monthly subscription that I
pay for so super simple so our mission
at Google is to transform organizations
by expanding the use of computing and we
believe we are well positioned to do
that with the chrome and the Android
operating systems and various solutions
that are built around it so for example
just looking at the retail vertical we
see lots of use cases that are stemming
with single purpose use cases that can
connect the entire supply chain from the
front of the store all the way to the
back of the store so here you have
employee devices shared employee devices
in the back office you have customer
facing kiosks you have digital signs in
the storefront you have data capture
handheld devices in an operational
warehouse and then you also have a
moving sales associate who is walking
around with an Android tablet and then
lastly one of the biggest pet peeves for
me is when I walk to a retail store you
have these amazingly long waiting lines
so this can be amazing if I can actually
have a sales associate who can walk up
and can use a mobile point-of-sale
system and can automatically check me
out right so there I have a very
seamless shopping experience
so again taking retail as an example
here we find that a lot of retailers are
trying to connect the online as well as
the physical store presence and to do
that they are accomplishing this in a
number of ways they're implementing a
range of solutions which are fraught
with your own problems so in the
left-hand side you see a situation
wherein you have an engineer
who is standing on top of a ladder in
front of a broken sign and he's actually
resorting to manual intervention if he's
probably gonna reboot the device to
bring that system back on so the
fundamental problem here is that there
is going to be a lot of downtime because
the signs are down and in addition it's
also very expensive
right and actually bringing a technician
out there to fix the problem and then on
the on the on the other hand you have
the classic problem where a lot of
retailers just choose to go the
old-school way and just have static
signs everything is paper-based this
results in also very static and very
expensive because now you're gonna have
printing costs you're gonna have to hire
people who will have to hang up these
signs replace these signs and you can't
do any kind of modern event triggered
marketing or notifications around it so
we believe Chrome OS and Android are the
best device platforms for providing
truly engaging experiences so Chrome OS
is an extremely reliable operating
system it provides an appliance like
uptime it's extremely secure and we have
designed Chrome OS from the ground up
with security in mind we probe offer
Chrome OS secure updates a verified boot
process isolation devices then the nice
thing is the OS updates are common and
get consistently applied across every
device form factor that Chrome OS
provides or Chrome OS runs on and this
results in an extremely low total cost
of ownership and lastly the platform is
very flexible you can easily support and
run any type of hitch
five app that has been designed for the
web and it also provides a broad support
for peripherals so Android also security
is our number one priority and Android
ships secure with on device protection
it offers multiple layers of ongoing
protection through cloud-based services
we use machine learning as well as event
correlation to detect and to make our
security systems really strong and
smarter over time so with Android and
Chrome OS we can now power literally any
type of form factor out there starting
with devices with screens so you have
smartphones tablets laptops all the way
to devices without screens so whether
it's a box or it's a stick and this
helps you promote use cases like smart
digital signage all the way extending up
to innovations in the Internet of Things
with IOT with even with Android things
so we're announcing two new devices
today and these devices have been
manufactured by a open it's called the a
open Chrome Box Mini and the a open
Chrome based mini so the device here you
see is called the a open chrome box mini
this device can be paired it's a rugged
device it can be paired with any screen
out there and can truly transform it
into a smart digital sign in addition
these are the e open Chrome based minis
and these devices can be used to power
any kind of high traffic zones so they
can be there is a 10 inch tablet 10 inch
tablet typer form factor it has touch
support so and these are good examples
of actually apps that are running so
it's actually off right now but let's
come back to it but these two devices
are also devices that will be running
Android apps and we announced that as
well I'll talk about that in a little
bit but we will be supporting Android
apps starting with chrome I'll stone 57
in kiosk mode and we'll quickly show you
a demo of the two apps that we have
running pull down from Google Play
so as an organization when you are
looking to transform your workplace so
there are some factors that you need to
consider when you are making the
decision in terms of what type of use
cases you want to support and what type
of solutions you want to deploy so the
first form factor is the first important
factor that you might want to consider
is first of all really identify what
problem you're trying to solve so is the
problem that you're trying to solve is
you want to have a completely bolted
down device that is stationary that is
not going to move around the device that
is probably of the right form factor for
you is probably a chrome base right it's
a device of this kind on the other hand
if it's a device where you have a moving
salesperson or a moving associate who's
walking around the store and is trying
to help customers in the store finding
products in the Shelf the device
probably is an Android tablet there are
also various price points that can
become applicable and price becomes a
really important criterion when you're
defining what type of solution to choose
and deployed so here for example if you
want to consider indoor signage where
you want to have where ruggedness does
not matter temperature sensitivity is
not matter in that case you could
probably consider a low cost chrome bit
which costs as low as $89 right so this
can be a good solution to quickly get
your internal corporate dashboards up
and running on the other hand if you
need to have a rugged device that works
and powers your outdoor signage that can
even power your billboards you probably
want a rugged device right so any one of
the open chrome boxes could actually
help you with that similarly if you have
a vert house and you have employees
working in the warehouse who need to
have rugged handheld devices as data
capture devices the Honeywell device or
the zebra device are probably right
devices that you may want to select and
consider Chrome OS also offers a variety
of different solutions that we have
built building on top of both the Chrome
and the Android platforms
however at Google we have been building
solutions around the chrome platform the
three specific solutions that we have
been building our public sessions
digital signage and single purpose
kiosks which I will talk about
a bit so first to describe each of these
three use cases one digital science so
I'll walk through all these three
examples also in terms of a retail
setting and how this works so consider
again you're a retailer and you have
Mary who is your most loyal shopper who
is I was walked into your store and your
store is completely outfitted with
digital signs smart digital signs which
are showing promotional content prices
and a lot of promotional information
which keep changing with the time of the
day so now the intelligent sign
recognizes Mary and it identifies her as
a woman and she's about say thirty
thirty-five years old and then as Mary
continues to walk through the store it's
providing her with the right content
relevant content or maybe access to
coupons or access to other type of
promotional links that she can take
advantage of which makes her entire
shopping experience to be truly
personalized and delightful so how does
this all work we promote this kind of a
solution using Chrome OS devices so you
can actually pair a screen a monitor
with a chrome box and you can get a
smart screen and Chrome OS inherently
supports beacon technology from Google
which is called the Eddystone beacon so
it comes in with a built-in sensor and
with Eddystone beacons the way it works
is the screen would now broadcast Eddie
Eddie stone URLs and any user in this
case Mary when she's walking around and
walking about the sign her smartphone
picks it up and then she receives
notifications in her smartphone where
she can actually click the appropriate
links to access coupons or promotional
content or anything of that sort right
so all of this is technology that is
possible today in addition when I spoke
earlier that the smart sign is able to
recognize Mary and determined that she's
a woman and she's probably about
35 years old that is possible using
integrations with the cloud vision API
so you can integrate with the cloud
vision API and that can detect even if
Mary is you can detect her emotions it
can detect her moods it could say Mary
is probably not very happy right now or
Mary is sad right and based on what her
moods are it can also provide relevant
contextual information that gets passed
on to her smartphone the second most
important solution that we have been
building is called a single app kiosk
and again in this case Mary now has
identified the items that she wants to
purchase and she can go and check them
out so she can use a chrome base to
actually go and check out the items it
could be a self-service checkout kiosk
or it could be a kiosk that where she's
been assisted by a sales associate and
lastly in the final scenario this is a
situation where at the time of checking
out Mary is asked if she wants to sign
up for a credit card how many of you
when you go to a store have been asked
do you want to sign up for a credit card
or do you want to sign up for a line of
credit from this and from this retailer
right it's a very common scenario and so
here Mary's asked to do that and she
says yes she wants to do it so she can
actually use this session it's called
public sessions who we have built this
on Chrome OS and with public sessions
Mary does not have to sign in with a
Google account in fact she doesn't have
to sign up with any account she just
gets into the session it's completely
private completely secure completely
incognito and within the session she can
quickly fill out the application and
then she's done and once she exits the
session all data on the session is
completely removed the session is
ephemeral any data in the device is
completely removed and biked out making
this to be a truly incognito session so
as your deployment scales right you
start with one device and now you want
to scale out to hundreds of devices or
even thousands of devices and also want
to scale out to many geographic
locations you may want to be able to
manage these devices as I mentioned in
the earlier scenario you wouldn't want
to have a situation where you're sending
out a technician or an engineer to every
remote site and
have that technician fix the problems
but instead you would probably want to
remotely manage your devices you want to
remotely manage your policies and push
the configurations through a remote
management console so Google offers a
web-based remote management console to
manage your Chrome OS endpoints and it's
called is the Chrome device management
console and with the Chrome device
management console you can do a ton of
stuff really so we can you can monitor
the health of the health of the devices
as an IT administrator you can push
policies you can detect connectivity
status which devices are online which
devices are offline you can also get
remote screen grabs you can schedule
automatic restarts and reboots we'll go
to a quick demo towards the end where
you can see some of these some of this
functionality in action and similar
options also exist with Android devices
that need to be managed and we work with
a number of third-party partners like so
te and MobileIron in AirWatch who
definitely provides similar offerings as
well and the most important thing and
the advantage of the chrome of the
Android platform ecosystem is the robust
app ecosystem that is out there so you
have a ton of applications out there
applications the first of all you have
access to over 1 million apps on Google
Play you also got access to several
chrome content management apps so you
have apps like Scylla one design app
space Sky kit all of these are rich
html5 content apps that can be deployed
on a chrome media player on a chrome box
and you can actually convert that into a
digital sign you can transform it into a
digital sign and today I'm also really
happy to announce the support for
Android kiosk apps so we you can
actually run Android kiosk apps on any
one of our list of supported devices
where Android apps are enabled today
we've got about four devices out there
in addition these two devices out here
are our hero devices for purpose-built
the Chrome
box many in the chromebase mini these
two devices will also support Android
kiosk apps so with this you can actually
get a fully lockdown immersive
experience you can use the same Chrome
device management console to push down
Chrome apps and you can also push down
the Android apps from play so here is an
example we worked with a retailer with a
partner in Australia called crowd DJ and
they have a very cool Android app that
is available in Google Play and this app
actually allows customers to control the
beat they allow customers to select the
tracks from Spotify right that they want
their customers in in gyms or in event
venues or in restaurants to actually
have access to so we can actually now
run this app this is the Android app
that is downloaded from play and it runs
on this device on the chrome based mini
right so they actually have this
piloting in a bunch of centers in
Australia similarly education one of the
biggest use cases for kiosk apps is
running assessments testing applications
in schools and with this functionality a
lot of schools can actually deploy
Android based testing applications which
can then be locked down to the device to
create a full immersive experience so um
why did it go through a quick demo off
maybe we can do a quick demo here of
turning off the device so that you can
actually see how the app looks like so
we have two devices Oh actually runs so
we have two devices so in this one
device we're actually running the IMDB
application so the IMDB app has been
downloaded from Google Play it's
installed in the device so we use the
Chrome device management console push
the app and then once the app is pushed
down the app instantly runs on the
device right it can be done remotely and
now you have this app acting as my video
kiosk right so I can pretty much run any
video it's hopefully the network is good
but you get the idea
so it does run right
okay I'm gonna skip the ad but this is a
completely lockdown immersive experience
right so it's lockdown and it's running
an Android up the second example is we
selected an app which is used by the
Hyatt Hotels so it's a Hyatt Regency app
it's used in your in their rooms
it's an in-room controller app so that
every guest who is in the hotel premises
they have this kind of a device that is
sitting by their bed stand and they can
actually access assets and properties
off the hotel and this is again an
Android app that is just downloading and
now running on this chrome based Chrome
OS device these are two good examples
and you can do the same thing with the
the chrome box mini you can pretty much
power this with any big display it could
be a display of this right a huge
display and you can then run Android
apps as well right so that's our goal
okay and lastly deployment is a huge
consideration when you're selecting any
of these different solutions whether
it's Chrome or Android with Chrome we
have really made the deployment process
to be fairly simple so it's really as
simple as getting a chrome box
connecting it to a screen whether it's
an HDMI port or a DisplayPort opening up
the Chrome device management console on
a laptop configuring the policies
pushing it down and then really you have
a digit digital sign right so the app is
immediately pushed on to the device and
then you have content that is changing
and it's reflecting based on who the
audiences in addition today we're also
announcing support for chrome kiosk
api's so these api's would really allow
third-party partners to build custom
solutions on top of the chrome
management console so you can now access
specific chrome policies to control
things like reboots or remote commands
so this is something that we also have
available and lastly last but not the
least this is one of the most exciting
features actually
the most common feedback we get from our
partners and our customers is that the
process of signing up and purchasing a
chrome kiosk is very complicated today
right you have to do a complex mechanism
of domain registration verification you
don't own the domain you're not an IT
administrator you don't own the DNS
records for the domains it's a very
complicated process so our goal is we
want to make the process for anybody
whether it's a mom-and-pop shop a flower
shop owner or a small team within a huge
enterprise to be able to very easily
easily sign up for a chrome kiosk right
so they should be just provide three
fields they need to provide your name
their email address and your phone
number so once they provide these three
fields they will automatically be able
to with a quick email verification and
SMS verification they will be able to
instantly access a web-based console and
then they will have to trial licenses
will be given to them so that they can
manage devices and they can then
purchase Moree right so we'll do a demo
of this as well and raj do you want to
help me with the demo demo hey everybody
my name is Raj dry Swami I'm a product
manager I'm a part of Chrome operating
system team so today like we are good
I'm just going to really quickly show
are really simple web-based sign up so
one of the one of the common feedback
that we always get is like hey I really
want to try Chrome kiosks I want to just
like put a couple of digital signs in my
retail store but the thing is like it's
like really complex I have to pay a
license fee I'm not even sure like how
to do this kind of stuff so here like
what we are seeing here is a simple
web-based signup form just go to this
URL like we are going to open it up by
end of this month
just like enter a bunch of details like
your name your email address your phone
number what's your business name and
what kind of domain that you want to
secure it's as simple as this and you
can go ahead and say like yes
have been create your account Raj
entered it I got an email address right
I got an email from him and that said
welcome to the chrome kiosk trial and I
can sign up for it right I then go and
follow the steps I click accept and at
that point so once once you get the
email once you verify that like you own
your you're the rightful owner for this
particular account you will also be
asked to verify your phone number it's
like as a second factor authentication
and once you do that you will you will
immediately get access to admin console
and we are very happy to announce that
all all online signups are going to get
two free licenses for 30 days so you
will get get access to our Google admin
console you can go to you can go to you
can go to device management with that
with the credentials with which like you
signed up for you will be able to enroll
any any chrome devices let it be chrome
base mini let it be chrome box many are
like any other Chrome device you can
just like enroll your device to this
particular account and I'm just like
going to show a quick demo of how the
things work so you go you go to like our
device settings and there is a setting
called kiosk settings and there are like
as Vidya said there are like multiple
partners who have published chrome
applications and also Android
applications that can run in kiosk mode
I'm going to select an app from one of
our partners they are called app space
there they do a lot of corporate
communications related digital signs so
you can just like add their app you can
just save save it again and then you say
like okay I want to auto-launch this
particular application just say like yes
I want enable health monitoring I want
to enable device log upload yes I have
notified my users and and that's all
about it like in a in a matter of like
less than five minutes if you could have
su yes you saw now you'll be able to
like get your digital signs up and
running in one of your retail stores or
in one of your office spaces and just
briefly you will be it's not just
configuring the app and pushing the app
there are a few things like yes you will
be able to monitor whether the whether
your device is online you will be able
to remotely troubleshoot you will be
able to remotely reboot the machines you
will be able to push down the network
configurations you can say like hey I
want my devices to connect to connect to
this network alone and you can even like
enforce policies like if someone is
going to steal the device let's say it's
it's it's it's getting this you're like
showing the device outside your store
you can say like nobody will be able to
use it like you can you can do like a
bunch of good stuff with with our Chrome
device management and of course like
whatever I highlighted today is like
only a minimal set of policies we have
like so many levers here with which like
you will be able to control your
deployment very easily
[Music]
you